BRETT LIDER: Hey, everyone.
We're here to talk about Android
Wear, and the always-on screen,
and your apps.
So I'm Brett Lider.
I'm the Design Lead
for Android Wear.
And this is David Singleton,
the Engineering Lead.
[APPLAUSE]
All right.
Android Wear has had
an always-on screen
from our launch a year ago.
It tells you the time
in the active mode.
It also has this
low power ambient
mode for showing you the time.
It's also really
great at showing you
your most important
notifications, such as Jeff,
who you probably saw in
the keynote yesterday.
He's trying to get in touch
with us for plans later tonight.
So I can wake the watch back up.
I can interact with
this notification.
But as app developers,
you could also
deliver powerful
user experiences
using these notifications, such
as controlling your home stereo
or navigating the real world.
So that's the always-on
screen as it exists today.
But we're here today to talk
about the always-on app.
And so before we get
too deep into that,
I want to set a little
context around what
it means for us, as people,
writing things down and having
an easy way to reference that.
So let's take a big step back
actually, 5,000 years back.
So the Mesopotamians first
started writing things down
on clay tablets for
ease of reference.
And actually, that's what kind
of kicked off civilization.
So the ability to write
something down, and refer to it
or show it to someone else
was a really powerful,
enabling technology.
But it had some downsides.
A clay tablet is heavy.
It's brittle.
You can only write on it once.
So we're humanity.
We work on things.
We make them better.
And so fast forward a
couple thousand years,
and you have papyrus.
So papyrus is flexible.
It's much more portable.
You can write on it with
ink, with multiple colors.
But it still has some bugs.
You can only write on it once.
It's not accessible to all.
It's not super flexible.
So again, we work
on things as humans.
And we're going to fast
forward through history
a couple thousand more
years to the 20th century
and the invention of
the cathode ray tube.
So this is transformative.
Having an electronic display
that you can put anything
on really changed
things and allowed
us to have lots of flexibility
in what we put on our screens,
what we put on our displays.
But again, downsides.
It's heavy.
It's bulky.
It consumes a lot of power.
And in the beginning,
they were very expensive.
So we work on it some more.
And we come up with the
segmented LCD display.
This addresses a
lot of the issues
that we talked about today in
terms of power and bulk, right?
Segmented LCD displays--
really light, really
portable, don't
consume much power.
But they have a really
killer downside,
which is when you're
designing the hardware,
you have to think about all
the information you could ever
want to put on the display and
bake that into the hardware.
So very inflexible.
So that's what brings us to
the present day with Android
Wear and the always-on
screen where you basically
have all the things that you
could want in a single device,
portability-- I'll get into
that in a second, sorry.
So let's look at the timeline.
We've had 5,000 years
of display technology.
And always-on has actually been
the vast majority of that time.
So let's zoom in to the far
right of the timeline here.
And you can see that
occasionally-on screens,
electronic screens,
have only been prevalent
in the 20th century.
The screen, that's your
tablet or your phone,
that you take out
of your pocket.
And you have to go and
grab it, and turn it on.
That's actually not been the
case for a really long time.
And so we're finally at the
beginning of the always-on era.
And so that regrettable period
without always-on display
is behind us.
And so now we do have our list.
We basically have color for
flexibility and expressiveness.
We have pixels to
display whatever we
want to display on this screen.
We have touch interaction so
users can manipulate and act
on whatever they're looking at.
And we have low power
so the display can stay
on all the time and all day.
And so to show us what
we can do with that,
we've got David to demo
the Android TV remote.
DAVID SINGLETON: Thanks Brett.
So hopefully that's
given you a flavor
of why always-on
displays are important.
Let's take a look at a real life
example of an application that
is using the always-on
feature that we just
introduced in Android Wear.
So last year at I/O, we demoed
the Android TV Remote Control
app, which is what
you can see up here.
And it's really great.
I've enjoyed using it, sitting
at home, controlling my TV
from my watch.
And it already makes great use
of contextual notifications
in the streams.
So I can just wake it up.
Tap this card.
And I'm going to go into
the Remote Control app,
look at my TV in the
picture-in-picture.
I can wake it up, can
swipe down to YouTube,
and I can start playing
a video right there.
So this is a great video that
I made of my ski holiday.
Previously with
Android Wear, if I
was watching this
video for a long time,
my watch would
eventually timeout
and you'd go back to the time.
But with always on,
there's a better way.
And what you can see here, the
latest version of the Android
TV Remote app, we've
actually integrated
the always-on feature set.
So we're back in the
ambient low power state.
You can see that the
TV remote is still
running in the foreground.
And it's decided to put the time
there in black and white mode
so that I can still
see what time it is.
And then, the great thing with a
real remote control, of course,
is it's right there.
So I can just pick it up if
I wanted to pause this video
or move on to the next thing.
And with the always-on
feature in the Android TV
app that we've just
introduced, I can now wake it.
I'm back in the remote control.
And I can instantly pause
this video, fast forward,
and skip on to something else.
So this is a really
powerful feature
for applications that
know that the user is
engaged in an ongoing activity.
And then when I'm done watching
video, all I have to do
is tap on the screen again.
I'm going to wake the watch.
I can just press the
hardware key on the side.
And I'm back at the watch face.
Now I have a general
purpose smart watch again.
So hopefully that's
given you a flavor
of what you can do with this
feature using always-on.
So let's switch
back to the slides.
Now that you've seen
some of the power,
let's take a look
at what you need
to do to enable these features
in your own applications.
So we've tried to make this as
simple as we possibly could.
And there are just
a few simple changes
you need to make to your
app to enable always-on.
The first thing
you need to do is
to take any activity
in your application
that you want to remain
in the foreground
when the watch goes into
the ambient low power mode,
and have it extend
from WearableActivity.
So this is a base
class that provides
all this functionality.
And then in your onCreate
method in that activity,
you simply need to
call one method, which
is called setAmbientEnabled.
And now, your activity will
remain in the foreground
when the watch goes into
its ambient low power mode.
There are also three
important call backs
that your activity
is going to get
to let you know
what's going on here
so that you can take
the appropriate action.
The first two, I'll
share right now.
The first one is
called onEnterAmbient.
So this is called every
time that the watch
is going from the high
power interactive mode
into that low
power ambient mode.
And you can see here, this
is a real code fragment
from the Android TV Remote app.
And you can see
what we're doing is
we're going to set the
background color to black.
We'll talk more about
that in a second.
And we're also going to
update the rest of our UI
to look different.
Turn on the time in
that low power mode.
The second one that
you need to know about
is called onExitAmbient.
So this is called when we move
from the low power ambient mode
back into the interactive mode.
And there, you just
reverse those changes
that you made as you
went into Ambient mode.
So that's it.
That's all you need to
do to have your app be
enabled for always-on.
A couple little housekeeping
things you need to do
as well as your code in
your Android manifest file,
you need to ask for
permission to use wake clocks.
You need to do this in both the
wearable and in the phone app,
if you're not already
using wake clocks
because the always-on
feature uses them internally.
You also need to
request and optionally
require support from the
Wearable Support Library.
This is the library
that contains
the definition of
that WearableActivity
that I said that you
would move to extending.
And that's it.
So with that, we
have been working
with a number of partners--
so developers that we've
given slightly early
access to these APIs
for a couple reasons.
One, to make sure we've
designed and built APIs that
work well and are
general purpose,
and also to see what they did as
they brought always-on support
to their applications in
order to distill some best
practices, which we're going
to share with you today.
So let's take a look at
a couple of examples.
First of all, let's go shopping.
So I'm in town
for I/O this week.
But I live in London.
I have lots of friends
in San Francisco.
And every time that
I come into town,
there are folks that want
all those British things that
are really hard to
get hold of here.
So I have this common use case.
I make a list of
groceries to go by.
I either make that on a piece of
paper or I put it on my phone.
And then I take myself off
to the local supermarket.
As I move around
the supermarket,
it's kind of cumbersome to keep
getting my piece of paper out
or to keep getting back into
the right app on my phone.
So with Android Wear and
the always-on functionality,
there's a better way.
And one of our partners, Bring!,
have added always-on support
to their shopping list app.
So let's take a look
at how that works.
Here I am at the watch face.
I go ahead and tap
on the watch face,
bring up the application
launcher, and start Bring!.
I created that shopping
list before I left home.
I can see I've got
three items to buy.
I'll go ahead and tap into that.
Open the list.
And now I'm in their
shopping list activity.
And this one is
enabled for always-on.
So the first thing I need
to get is Swiss chocolate.
Great.
So let's walk off to
the Swiss chocolate.
This is going to
take me a while.
So before always-on,
my watch would probably
have been back at the watch
face by the time that I
got to the Swiss chocolate.
But now, I can drop
my wrist, it'll
go into that low
power ambient mode,
and you can still
see, at a glance,
that you need to go
get the chocolate.
And also they've put
the time-on screen.
So that's great.
Let's walk off to the chocolate.
I get there.
I tap the screen to wake it up.
I can tap one more
time to mark that I've
got the Swiss chocolate.
I can swipe, move
to the next item.
English breakfast tea.
Definitely hard to get great
tea here in San Francisco,
but pretty easy back home.
I can walk there again.
I drop my wrist.
It goes into ambient mode.
I can still see, throughout that
whole interaction, what it is
that I need to get at a glance.
I get there, I tap the
screen, and mark it as done.
So I've got one last
thing to get, Marmite.
I hate Marmite, but I do
have friends that like it.
And it's much easier
to get back home.
So We'll walk there.
We'll drop our wrist.
We're in this low power mode.
We can see it's still
Marmite we need to get.
Get there.
Mark it off the list.
And then when I'm done
with all my shopping,
I can close the app.
And I'm back at the watch face.
I have a completely general
purpose smart watch.
So what's up next?
I've got my shopping.
I've packed my bags.
I need to get off
to San Francisco.
So let's board a plane.
The way that I'm sure all of
us are used to doing this-- I
show up at the
airport, I get given
a piece of paper, very
important piece of paper,
which I need to not forget.
But I'm going to need to
pull it out several times
as I move around the airport.
I don't know about
you, but I find this
a source of amazing anxiety.
I keep losing my boarding pass,
tucking it inside my passport,
putting it somewhere when
I'm going through security.
But of course, mobile
boarding passes
have made that a bit easier
because they're always
in your phone.
But how many times
have you found yourself
getting to the front
of the line and you're
busy looking at a web page.
You're checking
your email, trying
to do all those last things
before you get on your flight.
And it's kind of cumbersome to
get back to the boarding pass.
Well, with Android Wear and
the always-on functionality,
there's a better way.
So let's take a look at one
of the partners that have
implemented this functionality.
So I'll start on the watch face.
I can launch the
American Airlines app.
And here it goes directly
into the ticket for the flight
that I'm about to take.
I can see all the
details of the flight
right there, including
went it departs
and the gate number
that I need to go to.
If I drop my wrist and start
moving around the airport,
the watch is going to go
into low power ambient mode,
but my ticket is still
right there on screen.
And if the gate
changes, it'll update.
And I can glance down at it.
But probably what
I'm going to do next
is try to actually board
and go through the gate.
So I need that QR code.
I can tap my watch face.
I can do this amazing
fling gesture.
I get to a QR code.
And I can go ahead and
scan it at the gate.
If I get busy and drop
my wrist in that time,
it times out to this low
power ambient mode still
showing the QR code.
So that's pretty powerful.
And now Brett's going to take
us through a couple more.
BRETT LIDER: Sure.
So the day of a
big talk like this,
I like to go for a run in the
morning-- helps calm my nerves.
So let's do that.
A way that I might
do that today is
that I would go out and buy
a fitness tracking watch.
I would charge it, keep it
synced with my phone or laptop.
So that's kind of a hassle.
But I do want to
keep track of my run.
So let's see if there's
another way I could do it.
If I do want to look at my pace
and my distance as I'm running,
I could carry my
phone in my hand.
But I get really
sweaty when I run,
which is probably
a common thing.
And also, people running
with their phones-- at least,
I feel like I look like a
big dork when I'm doing that.
And whether or not
I am a big dork,
I don't want to feel like one.
So I don't think this is
a great solution either.
So with Android Wear, we think
that there's a better way.
I think we've lost the slides.
Hold a moment, folks.
All right.
So I can launch
the Endomondo app
just by tapping
on the watch face.
Tap on Endomondo
from the app picker.
And I'm in the Endomondo app.
And all I have to do is
hit this big button here,
and I'm recording my run.
Next slide.
Awesome.
So I'm now tracking my run.
The counter's going
to start incrementing
as I start running.
The distance will start
incrementing as well.
Here's the time going up.
And if I drop my
wrist or it times out,
it's going to go into this
low power ambient mode
and track my time and
distance about once a minute.
The screen will update
about once a minute.
And so at the end of my run,
as I'm tracking it as I go.
I can wake the watch back up.
And at the end of
the run, I've run
for 30 minutes and 30 miles.
And I can just save my run.
So my watch was a dedicated
run tracking device.
Now, it's back to being a
general purpose smart watch.
So we're pretty
excited about that.
I am at least.
And then our next use case
would be a day like today.
So at the end of I/O, after
watching all these talks,
talking with all of you
guys, being up here on stage,
I'm going to be really tired.
I'm going to want to go home.
And I won't want to have to
think about it very much.
So what's a way that we
could do that, today?
What's the way I would do it?
I would probably
get out my phone.
I would ask for navigation home.
And I would walk around the
streets of San Francisco
with my phone out.
Now that has some downsides.
I might bump into people.
I might walk out into traffic.
Someone might try to
take my phone away.
So let's not do that.
Let's do this a better way.
So with Android Wear, I
can just launch Citymapper.
And Citymapper's got this
great button that I love.
Get Me Home.
Yes.
And it's telling me, oh, we
think the best way to get
home is 25 minutes on BART.
That sounds great to me.
So let's just hit go.
And immediately,
Citymapper just tells me
everything I need to do.
I need to walk to
Powell Street, BART.
It's about nine minutes away.
And here's a map.
And here's the route.
It's just all
there, right for me.
So I can start walking.
And the watch will
timeout to ambient,
yet the information
that I need to know,
the next actionable
step, stays on screen.
And as I approach Powell
Street, BART and glance down
at my wrist, it'll actually
update, and light up,
and say, you want to
wait for this train,
it's coming in three minutes.
And again, after a few seconds,
it'll timeout to ambient,
but City Mapper stays
on top to help guide me
through my journey.
I think someone who's used
this app just came out
yesterday, told me it feels
like having a superpower walking
through the city.
In an unfamiliar city,
you can glance down
and know where you need to go.
It's pretty special.
So when I'm done, I
can hit the Home button
and be back to using
my watch for whatever
I want to use it for.
So thanks to Bring, American
Airlines, and Endomondo,
City Mapper, Zillow,
Golf Shop Pro, Runtastic,
and RunKeeper, KLM, Delta, and
Google Maps, and Google Keep.
These are all app
developers that
have tried to embrace
the always-on screen.
And what they've been able
to do is transform their apps
into an actual wearable device.
And this is one
of the reasons why
we're really excited about
the always-on screen.
Android Wear has been really
good at keeping the time
and giving you
your notifications,
and allowing you to
take quick actions.
People love it for that.
But it can be so much more now
with the the always-on screen
and always-on apps.
So it can be this immersive
navigation experience,
a fitness tracker
or a fitness coach.
It can be a to-do list manager,
help you get things done.
It can guide you
through your travel
and help you control your home.
So what you do
with it, we'd love
to see because we
feel like we're
at this point in
wearable evolution
where, prior to this
date, if you had
an idea for a
wearable experience,
you would have had
to go out and hire
hardware engineers,
mechanical designers,
industrial designers.
You'd probably have to do
some fundraising, maybe
a crowdfunding campaign or
find investors, contract
with an overseas manufacturer.
That's a lot of time
and energy and effort
just to even see if your idea,
a single purpose wearable idea,
is going to have
traction in the market.
Now with the always-on
screen and Android Wear,
you basically have access to
the entire Android Wear supply
chain.
So all of our 7 devices today
and all of our devices to come
can become your wearable
experience for users.
So we're really excited to see
what you guys do with that.
And to help you, we're going
to segway into best practices
on the design and
engineering side.
So we built-- and
this is actually
in our documentation--
the sample stopwatch app.
And on the left here, you see
the interactive high power
mode.
And on the right, you see
our low power ambient mode.
And we're going to
talk about the design
changes you want to make
between these two states.
So it's pretty simple.
The first is to, when you
transition to ambient,
you want to use a
black and white.
The two reasons for this
are that it saves power
on the vast majority
of devices, and it's
a strong visual cue to the
user that the device is now
in this low power state.
Pretty simple.
Second, you want to display
the relevant time units.
So this, again,
takes two flavors.
Because you're in a
long lived session,
the user might want to actually
know what the time of day is.
So we've included that in the
ambient display of this app.
Second is that since
the display updates
only about once a
minute, if you're
tracking time down to the
second, that doesn't quite
make sense.
And so you want to stop
keeping track of time
down to the second
and keep track of it
just down to the minute.
So you can see that here, we're
counting up minute by minute.
Third, you want to
remove any buttons that
are on the display
in the ambient mode
because tapping on the
watch face in ambient wakes
up the display.
And then, the user can
interact with the display.
So remove buttons when
you're in ambient mode.
And finally-- this only applies
to a small number of apps--
but if there's any
information on the display
that the user might not want to
have persist in ambient mode,
just take it out as you
transition into ambient mode.
So that's all you need to think
about from the design side.
And let's hear from David
on development stuff.
DAVID SINGLETON: Thanks Brett.
So one of the most
important things
to understand from a
development perspective
is that, as we go into
low power ambient mode,
we're actually doing
something pretty profound
in order to save battery.
And that is that we actually,
as much as we possibly can,
turn off the CPU.
It's pretty powerful.
So while your application
is still in the foreground,
the CPU is not running at all.
And most of these
development best practices
are about how you can
preserve that state so
that you're really making best
use of the user's battery.
So first thing to think
about is, as we said,
it's important to be
efficient in ambient mode,
it's also important to be
efficient in interactive mode
because now your application
is in the foreground.
It's essentially become the
home screen of the watch.
And that means anytime the
user performs the wrist gesture
in order to get into
interactive mode,
it's going to be your
app right on top.
That's really powerful
for you as a developer.
But it also means
that you need to think
about efficiency of
that mode just as much
as you do the ambient mode.
So for instance, this is not
the right time to grab some data
and transmit it across
the Bluetooth link
because spinning up
the Bluetooth radio
uses a lot of power.
This is probably also
not the right screen
in your application to show
any videos or animations that
run for a long time because
that's going to keep
the CPU in high power mode.
So be efficient in both
interactive and in ambient.
The next best
practice is to choose
the right approach for updates.
So when you're in interactive
mode, we do turn off the CPU.
But it is actually possible
to keep fresh information
on the screen.
And that's really important
so you can have a great user
experience.
But it is something
you're going to have
to do to choose the right
approach of when you're
going to make those updates.
And the first thing
that you might
need to do for your application
is not to update at all.
So we saw a great
example with Bring!.
I was shopping.
The next thing that I
needed to go pick up
was still the same until I
got there and woke up my watch
and could say that I got it.
So in the case of
an app like that,
there's no need to update
the display in the low power
ambient mode at all.
And that's great.
You're going to achieve
really great battery savings.
And that's where I'd like to
encourage you to go if you can.
Some other applications,
for instance,
we looked at the boarding
pass for American Airlines.
They might only need
to update the screen
if something changes.
So for instance,
the gate changes,
the time to depart changes.
We'll talk about that as well.
Then other apps might actually
need more frequent updates.
So let's take a look.
So I mentioned the
possible best practice
might be to update never.
But if you do need to
update periodically,
I mentioned that
WearableActivity gives you
three callbacks, but I've
only shown you two so far.
There's another one which
is called onUpdateAmbient.
So we need to go
back a slide here.
We think we've
skipped over a slide.
Here we go. onUpdateAmbient.
So this will be called
approximately once a minute
to enable your application
to update the display.
And you can go ahead,
invalidate your views,
and have them redraw themselves.
If you need to update
more frequently,
that's also possible.
Probably the best way to update
more frequently is on demand.
So for instance, if
you have incoming data
from the application that you
have running on the phone using
the data APIs, then those will
actually cause the CPU to wake
to handle the data.
And that's a place where
you can update your UI.
But if you remember
the Endomondo example,
that was a kind of
long running activity,
but where we wanted to maybe
tell the user how far they
traveled or how many
calories they burned
by updating periodically.
So Android already has
a great set of APIs
to enable you to wake up the
device, the phone, tablet,
or watch, periodically
with Alarm Manager.
And if you would
like to do that,
you can set whatever kind of
frequency of call back to wake
the device up and allow you
to redraw the ambient display.
It's really important here
to read the documentation
for Alarm Manager.
There are a couple different
ways you can set alarms.
And you need to use the
ones that end in _WAKEUP
because those are the ones that
will actually start the CPU,
if it's asleep.
And then that means you could,
for instance, wake up every 30
seconds, figure out how
far the user's traveled,
and draw that on the UI.
Couple of things to know here.
The first one is
the 10 second rule.
So I've been saying you
could wake up periodically
with this API.
Make sure that you're not
waking up more frequently
than every 10 seconds.
If you do, then
you won't actually
be achieving any
power savings at all.
And therefore, you might want to
think about, in my application,
how am I going to display
information such that if I
update less frequently
than every 10 seconds
it's still a great
experience for the user.
The second thing
to know is that you
need to be a little
bit careful when you're
using the AlarmManager API.
You're going to provide
a pending intent to say,
when your alarm goes off,
please start my activity again.
And you just need
to be a little bit
careful to use the right
flags with pending intent.
Make sure that you're
using the flags that
will cause the same instance of
your activity to be updated--
so there's a flag
called UPDATE_CURRENT--
rather than a whole new
instance of your activity
to be started in order
to handle that callback.
There's also a really
easy way to do this
if you put launchmode
singleInstance in your Android
manifest file.
All the details of this
are in the code lab
in the documentation that I'm
going to reference at the end.
The final best practice
is to test on your wrist
and not on the dock.
So I've mentioned that we put
the CPU in this low power mode
whenever we're in ambient
as much as we possibly can.
If you put your watch
on to the charging dock,
which is often what you'll
do when it's connected
via USB for development.
Because there's outlet power,
it won't put the CPU to sleep.
So you may see slightly
different behavior on your dock
as to if you took the
watch off every time you
put a new instance of your app
on the device, and then use it.
So make sure you
take it off and check
that it's behaving as you would
expect because the CPU will
actually go to sleep.
It's also important
to test on your wrist
because a lot of the
applications that you're
going to develop that
are going to have
glanceable information
on screen really
need to have a simple
UI as possible.
And we find that if you're
just sitting at your desk
and looking at your
device in one spot,
you may not actually
see all of the things
that you might need to change.
So get your device
on your wrist.
Walk around your
office if you need to.
Even better is take
your application
into the context in
which the user's going
to be whenever they're
controlling their TV
or buying their shopping.
And that'll help you
make really great choices
as you develop your
always-on apps.
So now that always-on
on Android Wear
watches to be many devices
in one, as Brett explained,
we're really excited to see what
device you're going to build.
So in order to do that,
here's what you can do next.
We have documentation at
developer.android.com.
The full URL is right there.
We've also developed
a code lab that
will walk you step by step
through the process of adding
always-on functionality to a
simple stopwatch application.
That's the end of our talk.
Thank you for listening.
Please give us your feedback.
And we have some time right now
for some questions and answers.
I think that there
are a couple of mics
out here in the audience.
There's one here
and one over here.
So if you've got questions,
step up to a microphone.
[APPLAUSE]
Thanks a lot.
AUDIENCE: Great presentation.
Thank you.
Oops.
Live mic.
Is there any facility
for multitasking
to have more than one screen,
more than one application
be available in
the low power mode?
DAVID SINGLETON: Great question.
The question is-- oh, everyone
could hear it on the mic.
So multitasking.
First of all, one thing
that's important to remember
is it is possible for
your Android Wear apps
to run in the
background in general.
So Android has very
powerful APIs for this.
And we run Android
on the watches.
So you can do
multiple-- multiple apps
can run in the background.
However, it is the case
that only one of those
can be in the foreground
at the same time.
So the idea here is
the user is involved
in a long session
where they're doing
something in the real world.
And your app can
continue to stay on top.
However, all those APIs that
we have had before today
still exist.
So one of the best ways to
get the user's attention
if something has happened
related to your app or service
is to post a notification.
And by default,
notifications will still
appear on top of always-on
activities in the heads
up notification mode.
So if you are running
in the background,
and you want to give
the user the opportunity
to switch to your app, which
could also implement always-on,
then post a notification, and
they'll be able to see that.
BRETT LIDER: A concrete
example of that
might be that you're
navigating and listening
to music at the same time.
And both of these apps
implement a full screen
version of themselves.
So let's say I was
navigating, but I
wanted to go switch my music.
So I hit the hardware button
to go back to the watch face.
And as I did that,
the app could actually
publish a notification
that was like, hey,
you're still navigating.
Here's your next turn.
And tap here to relaunch into
a full screen experience.
So then the user can basically
go down, launch their music
experience, change their
track, change their artist,
go back to the watch face
and access that previous app
via the notification.
So that's the suggested way
that you would go and do that.
And I think we have another
questioner right here.
AUDIENCE: Congratulations
on the presentation.
My question is all
Android Wear devices
must have off screen mode.
It's mandatory because Moto 360
does not support this feature,
I think.
DAVID SINGLETON: The feature
is supported on the Moto 360.
You'll see in
Settings that there's
an ambient screen setting, which
you can turn on and enable.
And obviously, always-on
apps do require
that the user has that setting
for the always-on screen turned
on.
Other devices, also possible to
disable the always-on screen.
So your app should
still make use
of the contextual notifications
that we talked about
if you want to have
the user get in there
during interactive mode.
AUDIENCE: But I have to, in
the Moto 360, all the pixels
are on, and all colors, right?
DAVID SINGLETON: Yeah.
Good question.
So I guess we can talk
about screen technology here
a little.
Brett mentioned that
the best practice
is to use black and
white and actually
keep as many pixels
black as possible.
And that's because a
lot of devices out there
have OLED screens.
And for OLED screens,
you only spend power
for the pixels that are lit.
But there are plenty of device.
And we're excited about the
range of display technologies
because they have
different traits.
For instance, there
are transflective LCDs,
which look great when
you're in bright sunlight
because they reflect
the light back.
And there are regular LCDs,
like the Moto 360 has.
So you should expect there
to be a range of display
technologies.
We've distilled
the best practices
so that you can make
good choices that
work across all of those.
So it's true that
for the OLED devices,
the pixels that you light
have the impact on power.
For LCD devices of any kind
then how many pixels you light
does not make so
much difference.
But we've distilled
the best practices
so that you can make
good choices across all
the devices in the ecosystem.
AUDIENCE: Thanks for
the presentation.
What I wanted to
ask you was do you
have any plans for better
haptics on Android Wear devices
because right now
one of the big issues
is sometimes notifications
just get lost.
I have the ZenWatch,
and the vibrator,
whatever is in there
isn't good enough.
And also to be able
to sort of enable
different forms of
interaction where you're not
forced to look at the screen but
still receive some information
just from a series of
vibrations or something.
DAVID SINGLETON: Sure.
So one of the things
I'd encourage you to do
is go and look at
the Vibration API
that exists already
because it's already
possible to use different
patterns of vibration
in Android.
That's an API we've
had for some time.
And we're definitely excited
about haptics in wearables,
but we don't have anything
to announce today.
Thanks.
AUDIENCE: Question.
When I'm in always-on
mode, is there
a way to get feedback on
how much CPU I'm using,
like a profiling tool?
DAVID SINGLETON: Great question.
So there are tools
that you can use to see
how much CPU you're using.
So you can take a look at
the Android Systrace tools.
It's part of the default SDK.
And that will allow you
to instrument your app.
You don't actually need to
change your app to instrument
the running session.
And you'll get deep insight into
how much CPU you're spending,
and exactly where
you're spending it.
So go look for
Systrace in the docs.
I think we've got time for
maybe one more question.
AUDIENCE: So I have a question.
When it is in ambient mode, can
I still force the CPU to run,
and the accelerometer and
gyroscope still running?
DAVID SINGLETON: Yes.
So the question is can
I still use sensors
when I'm in ambient mode.
And the answer is yes.
This new always-on
feature doesn't
change the way Android Wear
works with the existing API.
So it's already been possible.
For instance, you can use
those Alarm Manager APIs
that we showed you to wake up
and do some work with sensors.
But the best practices that
we talked about still apply.
So it's still important
to think about how you can
use the battery sensitively.
And you can definitely
continue to do that.
AUDIENCE: But I thought you
said the CPU goes to zero.
DAVID SINGLETON: That's true.
So one of the things that
we do-- and we do this
on phones and tablets, as
well-- is, if possible, we'll
try to turn the CPU off.
But the way that you would
already be using sensors,
if you wanted to use
them in the background
is to use the Alarm
Manager API, which
itself is going to wake
the device in order
to use sensor APIs.
And to be used very
carefully, there
are the Wake Lock
APIs that allow
you to hold the device
awake while you grab that.
And if you were already using
sensors in the background,
you will already be
familiar with those APIs.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
BRETT LIDER: And if you
have more questions,
we'll be on this side of
the room on the outside
after the session to chat
more with you if you like.
So thanks again for
coming out today.
I appreciate it.
DAVID SINGLETON:
Thank you, very much.
[APPLAUSE]